so next we'll hear from Brian Keating
talking about some of the experimental
evidence for inflation okay so I am the
token experimentalist on the panel
tonight so I brought with me my own baby
universe
I hold in my hand an actual universe
and in this universe
Sheldon's not wearing a shirt at all
it's the most popular one of all
okay so uh and he gave an excellent
introduction to these deep and mystical
theories that seem to be both in Vogue
and and quite quite speculative but at
the same time may have tremendous
tremendous impact just as The Big Bang
Theory was a pejorative the name itself
is a pejorative but is now accepted by
all but a few people in in certain parts
of the country
um as being as being exact exact
description of nature so now maybe it's
not so crazy to think perhaps we do live
in a Multiverse
so I want to talk about this Andy showed
this slide this is a famous woodcut from
the 1500s when they just had invented
Photoshop and what it what it depicts is
this ancient Quest cosmology is a very
easy science to do in one sense because
you can do it with just your eyes and
your brain and in fact that's how early
humans did it that's the oldest science
people looked up and wondered and this
depicts this this character looking back
in space and as Andy said your eyes just
like a telescope are time machines so
you can look back in space you're
looking back in time so things that are
far away from us this artist who
conceived of this wood cut was
conjecturing what they might look like
now where this looks not too dissimilar
from some of the Escher paintings and
and wood cuts that we saw at the end of
Andy's talk so how crazy is it really to
speculate about such things and it's
really as I said one of the oldest
quests of humanity here's a more modern
depiction of it that I've stolen and and
and this depicts sort of a very crude
space-time diagram that shows things
today down here and then in the past
this beach ball uh flattened out and
laid flat as as if you're God looking
down on this region of the Multiverse
and the preceding the preceding Epoch to
when these most ancient photons left uh
the the primordial plasma that that
Epoch we believe uh is called inflation
I'll talk about that because the
hypothesis is that if inflation occurred
as Andy mentioned in many models of
inflation it still is continuing it
still exists and I have so-called
Eternal inflation you cannot shut it off
in that case there may be an Infinity of
universes and in fact this diagram may
be wrong there may be no dawn of time
and we may be back to the old
Aristotelian and pre-aristitalian notion
that the universe is infinitely old and
that baby universe is perhaps spawn
cyclically into and out of existence
I'll spend a lot of time focusing on
discoveries that we made using this
image and images like it with our
telescope at the South Pole called bicep
and how we infer from the properties
that we see here what this Epoch might
have been like and then the logical and
extrapolation that you must make is that
if this uh if this occurred if this
inflationary Epoch occurred then perhaps
something like the Multiverse must also
be mandated in some theories of physics
both from a coupling of of the
inflationary high energy physics of the
early universe and also things like
string theory as Andy mentioned
this has attracted a lot of attention uh
from worldwide organizations this is on
the front page our Discovery with bicep
two the so-called space ripples of the
Big Bang Smoking Gun so I always I
always like this this headline down here
from The Economist sounds like some guy
just suddenly sees the start of the
universe wow you know if you're looking
in one oh I saw it I saw it it's like a
meteor
um and then of course the the um the
best the best newspaper in all of
science is of course the UCSD Guardian
which is a little bit more circumspect
and and very calm in their notion they
said UCSD scientists prove inflation
Theory well that's pretty awesome I I
don't think you can even prove a theory
in physics let alone the fact that we
did it all by ourselves which we did so
I'm going to talk to you about this and
I always say it's a mystery it's a it's
a Mysterious Universe in which we live
there's a mysterious Galaxy not too far
from here where you can buy David's
books but there's also a mysterious
Multiverse and so I don't want you to
ever come away especially I see a lot of
young people in the audience and that's
wonderful full I want you to come away
with the notion that there's way more to
do than has been done and the people
that are up here really haven't even
scratched the surface and it's your job
to come up not just with the theories
and the conjectures but actually follow
through with it learn the math learn the
science learn the physics build the
experiments travel these distant places
that's what I want to inspire you guys
to do and and even we have some some
older people that could be inspired to
do that too
so I always say it's a mystery and the
Mystery like all great Mysteries you can
maybe phrase in the form of a murder
mystery and I'm going to lay out a few
different of these bullets and and I'm
going to hope to hopefully motivate the
fact that there is evidence that
inflation occurred and then following on
from Andy's talk that perhaps if
inflation occurred there too uh
therefore also did the Multiverse the
Multiverse somehow follows from this
explanation but I'm going to leave in a
little wrinkle at the end so I want you
guys to stay tuned I'll wake you up for
the end so I'll talk about the scene of
the crime where we go uh and what the
early very early Universe was like I'll
talk about our crime lab where we built
a forensic tool to appraise what the
yearly Universe must have been like and
then the so-called Smoking Gun as the
New York Times front page decried that
we seem to believe is indicative of this
inflationary explosive expansion of
space-time and then perhaps the jury's
still out there's still some controversy
about our results and even some some
very interesting conjectures for the
future
so just a very quick diagram this is
probably the most technical diagram I'll
show this is a slide that our
collaboration
put just to demonstrate the major
features of cosmology and and one slide
it's very difficult to do but
nevertheless it starts with a big bang
at least our portion of the Multiverse
or in the region that we when I was a
kid there was only a universe okay so so
I have to get used to it just like when
I was a kid there were nine planets but
then people like Adam bergaster and
others came along and killed off Pluto
and so and so now I have to always
correct myself that there's only eight
so we talk about the Big Bang as being
the local origin of as Andy said this
observable universe that we can detect
that's roughly 40 plus billion light
years across that instant is called the
Big Bang time equals zero so you set
your watch and then roughly a trillionth
of a trillionth of a trillionth of a
second after that came this violent
expansion of space-time called inflation
and then after that things in events are
listed here that are a little bit more
prosaic in terms of their impact but but
um but they're all observable relics
they all produce relics that we can see
today even if they're not in the form of
light we can detect the processes the
fact that we observe elements today
Light Elements like helium and hydrogen
those are relics left over from The Big
Bang very little hydrogen can be can be
formed outside of laboratory so what we
see is residual primordial evidences
this is Trace forensics from The Big
Bang itself
um when the protons combine with
electrons that were around since the
very beginning then the the cosmic
microwave background or CMB is formed
and this is this famous three Kelvin
background that's depicted here and when
a globe of the sky flattened onto onto
this beach ball
and uh this depicts what you'd see with
your eyes if your eyes were sensitive to
microwaves and you looked out at the
night sky you wouldn't see
constellations you wouldn't see stars
planets or galaxies instead you'd see
fluctuations in the microwave
background's temperature as intensity
and its polarization and that's this
Epoch here and so what we're trying to
do is use this image that we've made and
other groups have made of the of the of
the very early Universe 380 000 years
after the big bang take this image and
use it as a type of film okay so it's a
little bit strange to think about light
being a film and nevertheless we have to
think about it in that way we're
attempting to expose waves of gravity on
these photons okay so probably half the
audience doesn't remember film but but
half the audience does
um so so a film was this ancient thing
that we used to use 10 years ago to take
pictures and it would expose light here
we're not exposing light or exposing
gravity waves of gravity gravitational
radiation from the the inflationary
Epoch on this background so it's as if
we're looking at this beach ball and
what we're trying to see are not the
temperature fluctuations themselves but
distortions and ripples this thing is
wiggling like a ball of jello and those
those Wiggles are imprinted by waves of
gravity those waves of gravity are
produced during the epoch we call
inflation
we built a telescope to do that and in
doing so we uh we we were Guided by the
fact that we've confirmed many of the
predictions of inflation Andy mentioned
a few I'm not going to go over them but
inflation is one of the most well-tested
if not proven theories despite the
ucsd's guardian headline
it cannot in some sense be proven but
even even to the extent that we can
understand ways to falsify it it's been
it's been passed with flying colors so
we can't say that we've proven it unless
we can rule out every one of an Infinity
of possible Alternatives but in this
case we have so much credulity in the
model that it behooved us and and myself
to invent this experiment to go after
this unique signature of inflation
called gravitational waves that produce
so-called b-mode polarization so we're
looking at this pattern of microwaves
they have polarization properties
associated with them just like polarized
light reflects off the ocean surface you
can use polarized sunglasses to see it
and we're looking back at this pattern
to see waves of gravity exposed from the
very earliest instances after the big
bang so what is the CMB I want to show
you this uh just a kind of cartoonish
glimpse so if you go out into low earth
orbit and you looked and your eyes were
sensitive to microwaves this is what
you'd see an amazing depiction the
beauty the you know the grand Elegance
if you're a religious person this is the
face of God it's so beautiful no this is
what you'd see to First approximation
you'd see nothing it would be this
uniform boring puke orange glow that
your eyes would detect no discernible
pattern from this is the so-called three
degree Kelvin microwave background
signal this is the primary tool that
Precision cosmology has been used to
extract the parameters of the very early
Universe now if you take away the flux
the the average level that you see in
each Direction on the sky you're left
with these fluctuations like on this
beach ball
and this is quite this is quite a
exhilarating map to see an image like
this was called by Stephen Hawking the
like looking at the face of God
ironic because he's a devout atheist but
nevertheless looking at these images
looking at these patterns we've refined
our understanding of the global
properties of the universe its age its
mass its energy it's uh it's it's it's
possible future Evolution it's just
incredible to think of everything we've
accomplished just with this and now
we've endowed it with another observable
call that's polarization which I'll talk
about briefly so it's discovered in 1965
so I always say it's the last great
discovery in astronomy from northern New
Jersey I'm a New Yorker so I I'm
entitled to make fun of New Jersey
and it was discovered actually
serendipitously uh back when this was
the entire internet so Steve and and Sue
and and Cindy are here from ViaSat so
this used to be the entire internet it
was one satellite that communicated
around the entire Earth you bounce
signals off of uh even even more slowly
than you could do with a with an old 300
baud modem and you'd be able to
communicate with it but when they
launched it they found they couldn't get
rid of this glow in the background
that's seem to come from all directions
and that of course turned out to be this
three Kelvin or 2.7 Kelvin microwave
background radiation so that was its
Discovery they won the Nobel Prize for
this in 1978 and uh in the old days I
usually say to people you know if you
tune your television to a UHF station
that's no there's no signal local signal
you would get static on it but nowadays
no kids know what static is okay YouTube
never gets static
um so uh but about one percent of the
static on an old-fashioned CRT type
monitor would be from The Big Bang
itself
so the the orange glow that you saw
originally is the background radiation
it's three Kelvin then there are tiny
little fluctuations predicted by our
late colleague art wolf who was at UCSD
predicted that there should be
fluctuations in the microwave background
only two years after its Discovery quite
astounding uh prediction and that was
born out in 1992 when the Kobe satellite
measured the uh these imprints these
fluctuations in the microwave background
for the first time and uh that was uh
later awarded the Nobel Prize in 2006 to
George Smoot and John Mather and those
fluctuations those fluctuations led us
to believe that there must be some Force
responsible for the fluctuations on the
largest scales in the universe just to
give you an example of how small I say
these are large so the the microwave
background itself is three degrees
Kelvin subtract away three degrees
Kelvin you're left with fluctuations
that are about one part in a hundred
thousand how big is a part in a hundred
thousand well the surface of a bowling
ball if you map the the surface of a
bowling ball and compared it to its
average radius the fluctuations are
about a part in 10 to the fourth or
apart in ten thousand meaning that the
surface of a bowling ball which most
people consider pretty smooth is
actually much much rougher than the
surface of the last scattering surface
than this image would be if it were
depicted as a bowling ball again not my
bowling ball because I'm a terrible
bowler has a lot of dents in it so the
question is where do these fluctuations
come from and the inflationary model has
posited that these fluctuations come
from Quantum behavior in the early
Universe in the fabric of space-time
itself so what are we trying to do
we're trying to take this image this is
now just a purple and blue cut this is
the actual Kobe image of the full Sky
laid out flat again and we're trying to
understand from this image that we see
that dates to uh 10 trillion seconds
sounds like a lot it's 380 000 years
after the big bang we're trying to infer
from that what did the universe look
like a trillionth of a trillionth of a
trillionth of a second after the big
bang 50 orders of magnitude
extrapolation from the physics of 380
000 years after the big bang to
essentially right at the beginning of
time so what would that be like doing in
more human terms in a more human scale
so imagine uh you look at this creature
over here you biologist here will
recognize this and and if you do
recognize it please come to Gattaca
event on August 11th this is what you
look like a thousand seconds after you
were conceived okay this is called the
blastocyst it's roughly 100 to a
thousand cells assembled into this nice
little soccer ball package and if you
were trying to extrapolate what this
image looked like by looking at say this
this handsome devil here if you were
looking at him
and you're trying to extrapolate from
this image
how could you possibly expect to do that
okay so here's David our lovely
co-collaborator tonight so here he is at
2 billion seconds old I think that's
roughly correct you guys can figure out
how old that makes him in more human
terms now imagine trying to do this
looking at a picture of him and
inferring what his blastocyst looked
like I think he looks like his mother
there but um this is only a factor of 2
million extrapolation This Is 50 orders
of magnitude 46 orders of magnitude more
and and yet we we think that we can do
such a thing and that has to do with the
Simplicity although it's complicated the
Simplicity the elementary nature of
space-time at very very early epochs
when the universe produced the CMB
radiation that we see so how do you do
that well it starts with a pairing of
theorist and experimentalists thinking
about ways that you could observe
directly the signature of inflation so
what inflation predicts is that there's
a background just like there's a
background of light there's a background
of gravitational waves they come through
space-time and they shake it and shudder
it and it causes Tremors and
reverberations those induce a specific
kind of swirling Motion in the uh in the
polarization patterns that we see in the
Big Bang that's called B mode
polarization for cognizente it's it's an
analogy to the magnetic field which is
written as a certain Vector operation so
we attempt to measure these little
polarization orientations and their
intensity on the entire sky or at least
on this patch of sky that we can observe
and The Smoking Gun has been called many
times to observe this pattern this is a
simulation and I'll show you later some
real data and you can compare for
yourself so how do we do that we set out
we built an experiment called bicep one
and then we built a successor called
bicep 2 including uh the very hard work
of my graduate student John Kaufman
who's in the audience who just became Dr
John Kaufman this is a telescope which
is not only one of the world's most
powerful telescopes it's also the
world's most southern telescope and the
coldest telescope in the known universe
and I'll explain why that is in just a
bit here it is if you ever see this
picture you're in really bad shape
because this is sunset at the South Pole
which happens once per year in March in
the in the uh towards the end of March
when spring starts for us that's when
fall starts at the South Pole so you
won't be getting out anytime soon if you
see this beautiful sunset it's a
relatively large collaboration although
not compared to say a particle
accelerator
about 12 or 15 different institutions
and we built this experiment we started
with bicep one in 2005 and we upgraded
bicep two and we have many more upgrades
still to come this is what the telescope
looks like before it was shipped down to
the South Pole it's a refracting
telescope it's actually not that big
this length here is about five feet long
but the unique thing about this
telescope is that we design it to be
cooled down almost to the temperature in
fact to the temperature of the cosmic
background radiation itself so it sits
at three degrees Kelvin the warmest
parts of it are at three degrees Kelvin
it sits on an ordinary telescope Mound
it can scan back and forth look up and
down quite simple
if you did a cross section through it
you'd see at least in the original
design it stands for background Imaging
of cosmic extra Galactic polarization
light comes in it's a refracting
telescope like Galileo used to First
change Mankind's conception of what the
universe was like
405 years ago with the training of his
small refracting telescope on on Jupiter
and on the moon so light comes in gets
focused on detector the detector arrays
sit at sit at a quarter of a degree
above absolute zero so these are cooled
down to 453 degrees Fahrenheit sounds
really cold and in fact it is
uh people wonder what the lenses are
made out of it's very simple we use a
very high Purity version of what we used
to have in these old milk jugs I don't
know if I've never seen one in
California maybe they're banned uh but
uh but it's just high density
polyethylene it makes a good lens it's
transparent from microwaves and induces
almost negligible polarization
contamination
so now where would you put such a
telescope well here's the Palomar
Observatory so if you converted before 2
billion seconds into years you can
calculate what year David was born and
I'll just tell you that he was born so
they built this telescope for David this
was built the year before he was born so
that he could use it to think about the
universe as he's done throughout his
career this telescope though was built
and put in uh north of Julian and that
was done so for a reason because in 1949
that part of the of San Diego was quite
dark and its background what it's
looking for is light so he had to put it
somewhere dark we wanted to put our
telescope somewhere cold because we're
looking for something that is analogous
to heat so we want to take it somewhere
cold so we took it to Antarctica
and if you go out into space you can
look and look at an article like this
and the center of the Earth's axis the
southern point on the Earth's axis of
rotation is the South Pole and it's a
continent Antarctica is an actual
continent I actually brought some pieces
of it home with me the second time I was
there don't tell the governor no there
is no Governor there it's a lawless
continent there's only about 1200 people
there at any given time in the summer
and right now in the winter there's
about 200 people so the entire continent
is popular with 200 people so you can
actually get to a lot of superlatives I
was thinking when I was down there I
mean I've never been like you know it's
hard to be like the fattest person on
the North American continent but I could
actually do it in Antarctica I could be
the fattest I could be you could be the
shortest the tallest the oldest the
youngest uh see there's a continent of
superlatives including the fact that
it's the highest continent it's the
coldest continent it's the windiest
continent the South Pole sits at about 9
000 feet above sea level so it's a
little bit of the way into space where
you'd like to be ideally if you go uh to
this website in the summertime you'll
see a picture that looks like this right
now it'll be completely dark but there
is a webcam that shows you what the
weather conditions are like and it's
usually 100 chance of white and if you
think about it like a snow forecast this
is 9 000 foot deep base if you think
about skiing okay but unfortunately it's
all flat so you can't really get too far
you can go cross-country skiing we go
there despite the fact that there are
very known to be a very hostile natives
that live there despite that fact we
still went there so so it's very
dangerous environment but
some of my colleagues are here they
treat me worse than that okay so when
you go down there there's no Walmarts
there's no targets you can't buy clothes
when you're down there really besides
souvenir t-shirts to give to your
friends uh so instead you have to stock
up with all the clothing you're going to
use for the next month two months nine
months or a year you pack them into
these bags and you take all these
articles of clothing including these
really cool uh semi-inflated Moon boots
we call them so that you won't get
frostbite if you wear normal sneakers
your your feet will freeze due to the
conductivity through the rubber
uh you catch a flight hopefully if you
wake up in the morning at five in the
morning in New Zealand uh you don't go
outside and see this but the first time
I went down I did this is a C-130 cargo
plane that flies from Christchurch New
Zealand to the McMurdo Continental base
in the U.S this is also one tenth of the
New Zealand Air Force it's pretty
interesting okay you sit there it's a
beautiful very spacious lots of legroom
no it's terrible environment to be on if
you notice there are very few Windows if
any the pilots have Windows thankfully
but there's only two or three other
windows on the whole plane there's no
bathroom on the plane you have a little
pot uh called The Honey Bucket don't ask
me why they call it that and you're
you're served you know your first class
meal is in a bag of some mystery meat
and you sit knee to knee for uh luckily
it's only about 11 hours okay so uh but
you build up a lot of Frequent Flyer
points uh and eventually when you end up
getting to the South Pole the South Pole
is quite a beautiful place to to be at
least the first day you're there then it
gets kind of monotonous some people love
it John Calvin he loves it I get tired
of it you land here's the Passenger
Terminal okay this is the Admirals Club
presidents Club over here if you pick up
your light remember what this looks like
because you might see a picture of it
later on okay when the early original
explorers got there 102 years ago they
they skied up from sea level to 10 000
feet almost over waves of frozen snow
called sastrugi and as I said up above
crevasses and terrible terrible
environment we make it there in three
hours from the coast even on the c-130s
and this is a sort of scale model of
what they would have looked like in
Photoshop they weren't so happy and in
fact Robert Falcon Scott said great God
this is an awful place and he little
didn't know he would die two months
later trying to get back from the South
Pole to his Fuel and food Depots
nowadays I say it's an awesome place so
this is the actual access on which the
Earth is turning pretty cool so I can
run around the world
and even for somebody slow like me you
can do it pretty quickly but I say it's
in place because nowadays it has a
kitchen a greenhouse libraries a sauna
can you believe it a basketball half
size basketball court and many many
other amenities you have to prove to
your mother that you made it there so
you take a you take a selfie and you
start walking to work and there's bicep
so we built this Observatory back in
2005 and here's the outhouse
and this Outhouse if you remember what
the Passenger Terminal looked like is
very very reminiscent of what the
passenger term would look like I'm
always hoping they get that right uh
this is a site that also means they're
going to spend the winter there this
means the Sun is going down the sun
doesn't go straight down like it does
here roughly at some steep angle it just
grazes the Horizon in fact you don't
know where it's going to go down when
you're down there so just circles around
you can barely see a tinge of green not
from the laser pointer but you can
actually see the Green Flash for over
several hours when you're down there
this is taken by our winter over the
first season denim arcats I always tell
people they're like what's it like to be
there and I say it's great the pay is
awesome you get 75 000 and all you have
to do is work one night
there's the sun going down
okay so what happened what did we
actually observe well remember this
prediction this is a simulation one of
the nice things about making a big
Discovery potentially like this is that
you get places like the Washington Post
to do your graphic arts so they did a
simulation this pattern taken of what
you'd see if there were gravitational
waves and here in fact is real data this
is not a simulation we can compare the
predictions to what a simulation very
detailed simulation would predict and it
shows exact exact agreement so we have a
great confidence in it and and moreover
the scientific Community has spent many
many months three months we've had over
uh over 600 different Publications
here's just this mattering of them uh
incl as of last night there's 600
Publications that are citing our results
dissecting it this is what scientists do
they have to check and closely observe
and make sure that they can confirm and
reproduce your results otherwise it's
not scientific
so here are the results uh the most
gratifying thing was this article in the
best science news journal there is the
onion it said top theoretical physicist
R B singers meet to debate the meaning
of forever so down here it says we can
observe long-term phenomena like the CMB
primordial B mode polarization and the
love between India Arie and her man
all of which seem to have existed since
the universe's infancy and I want to
make them change it to R and B modes
because that's okay so when you go back
to this we think that we've observed
this imprint of gravitational waves
produced by inflation so if there was an
inflationary Epoch what does that imply
well it implies as Andy said perhaps
there's this Infinity of universes
called the Multiverse there's no not
necessarily a proof of it but if this
can be confirmed it would be very strong
motivation that perhaps something like
the Multiverse isn't too crazy
just finish up with a couple questions
um uh that I will want to ask David and
Andy later on if you guys don't ask so
what can you say about religion this
quote from Paul Davies is quite
evocative I'll just get cut to the point
he says that the Multiverse at a certain
level seems to be at least in the
anthropic or finely tuned versions seems
to be reminiscent of religion not as a
pejorative but just seems to be
philosophically
um uh at least isomorphic in some sense
to a religious Theory or to a religious
concept rather not a theory so this is a
very interesting article that I
encourage people to read getting back to
Galileo what can we say about the God
and the Universe I just say stay tuned
if he had a big bicep perhaps he
wouldn't have faced the Inquisition like
this and thank you very much and see you
in November hopefully
[Applause]
uh Brian you've you've talked about the
discoveries of empirical evidence
through cosmic background radiation
gravitational waves of the Big Bang
what
physical evidence might we achieve
someday
to demonstrate the reality of
multiverses
yeah so there are different classes so
the question was what other types of
empirical evidence might prove or
motivate the fact that there might be
indeed a Multiverse so there are
different levels of of predictions and
models that predict uh startlingly
obvious signatures
David actually showed one where you have
these two circles on the sky in opposite
places and people have looked for that
those signatures in the in the cosmic
background radiation as well seeking to
to perhaps detect the collision between
two of these baby universes within the
Multiverse so that's that's perhaps one
of the most obvious ones then there are
different levels of credulity if you're
willing to accept the notion that a
discovery of gravitational waves proves
or motivates inflation and that
inflation must be difficult if not
impossible to stop that it must be going
on everywhere so even though we might
not detect these other universes uh
similarly we we believed 100 years ago
that atoms you know where the most
finely grained substance that we could
possibly detect and observe in the laws
of nature where as we knew it back then
now we know much more so I think we'll
winnow down the possibilities first and
then what can delve into potential other
observable signatures but I should say
that it's it's motivated equally well
from inflation Theory and string theory
and I don't know of a way
observationally to prove it from the
string theory side there there are some
ideas very speculative in these versions
of string theory where you have these
large extra Dimensions like these
brainworld scenarios that David was
mentioning
um we we have some evidence that's very
you know intriguing this is the idea of
so-called Dark Matter it seems like
there's a lot of missing mass in the
universe and some people speculate that
one way of explaining this is that it
could be due to the gravitational
influence of other brains farther away I
don't know if this is correct but that's
the kind of a thing where maybe there
actually already is evidence out there
for other universes and we just need the
theoretical and film topical framework
in order to really elucidate that
I think the notion that there might be
brains next to ours we already
that gravity
our brain whereas some other forces
can't in which case we might be feeling
another brain above another below and
wouldn't they cluster their galaxies
near ours too by the gravitational
influence and this would explain some of
the effects that we see in our Galactic
rotation if I might also add those of
you who are artists I didn't mention it
if you're interested in pursuing any of
these ideas
um for
possible performance art about the
Multiverse get in touch with Sheldon
brown at or any of us uh care of the
Clark Center yeah great
uh can we move the microphone around
throughout the room please
okay uh
start over there yep
hi and thank you very much I thought
this was all fascinating I have a
question um I I've been studying this
for about 30 years and I'm just
wondering if any or all of you may have
looked at this from a slightly different
direction which is basically from the
direction of the golden ratio the
Fibonacci sequence
having looked into that I found it
fascinating that just about everything
that's considered beautiful or balanced
is based on that ratio about 1.61
something and the more I looked into it
whether it's the arrangement of the
pistols of a sunflower or the curvature
of the Nautilus see Nautilus or the
curvature the human ear or the spiral
nebula that you look into in where the
curvature of a wave all is built on this
same ratio throughout nature and I think
in 2003 which is where I'm going with
this if I'm not mistaken French
cosmologists had deduced that the actual
shape of the universe was a dodecahedron
which again is built on this same ratio
which you would think is an artificial
shape so in getting into Multiverse
Theory I'm wondering if you've looked at
that that ratio what a role it could
play in all of this and having a
descriptor for what this all looks like
and how it fits together
I've not looked at that I don't know
have you guys looked into that well it
occurs to me that we like it in part
because we're constantly perceiving us
around us and that natural phenomena
that add our additive processes like the
creation of crystals the creation of
branches on a tree
that these would tend to follow a
Fibonacci Sequence if they're adding in
a relatively
uh moderate way
so it may be it's just the matter that
when Nature adds things to adding things
to adding things that it occurs a lot
and we find it Pleasant because it means
that whatever is going on is healthy
that's just a speculation that's just a
Sci-Fi and one quick follow-up question
to that is that I don't know if any of
you have seen the I think it's some of a
famous picture on the internet but they
did a slice of a mouse's brain and
illuminated it and then they overlaid a
picture of the universe and it was
nearly identical
well one of the things that's been out
lately is is if you take a look at the
Sistine Chapel and if you look at the
funnel
Singularity whole
that God is emerging from with his
cherubs with his hand to give the spark
of life to Adam
it's shaped exactly like a human brain
with the um with the filigrees coming
off exactly where the cerebellum is and
his hand coming straight out of the
prefrontal lobes interesting yeah my
student John Kaufman thank you for the
question my student John Kaufman is a is
a student of this type of Art in the
microwave background and he actually
found a picture a very distinct picture
of a rabbit in our data set it's quite
beautiful can we pass the microphone
around
Cosmic rabbit hole
maybe in the way back I see someone
who's had her hand up for a long time
so if there were specific requirements
in terms of the constants and the laws
of physics that were required for life
to begin in our universe
and there are also bubble other
multiverses where laws are different how
could other universes support life
hmm maybe Andy you can address that so
we we really don't know very much as
much as we would like about How likely
life is to come into existence what we
can say are things that we think are
crucial prerequisites for our kind of
life
um and you can make some some pretty
plausible Arguments for what are the
kinds of prerequisites you need for life
in any case for example you can have
parameters like of cosmology where the
universe collapses after a refraction of
a second I don't think anything's going
to happen very interesting there so so
and and you can have
um the universe expand and accelerate so
fast that everything just becomes empty
and all the matter is diluted I don't
think things are going to happen there
that are interesting so it could be that
that if you looked at this whole
Multiverse by by some measure most of
the universes are really uninteresting
from our perspective maybe most of them
don't have life at all and so this is
still an open question we actually
really don't know how to do statistics
specifically
sorry oh go ahead could there be other
universes that don't necessarily support
life but have things like similar solar
systems planets stars in the same kind
of uh way that we do it's certainly a
possibility because we have a real lack
of knowledge here we know things that
are that are necessary conditions for
life like having a planet but we don't
know what the sufficient conditions are
so we don't know how likely it is for
life to start for evolution to get going
I I personally think it's quite
plausible that you could have a universe
with planets but life didn't evolve it
really depends on the answer to open
questions which we don't understand
about How likely it is for
self-replicating molecules to kind of
get going
yeah the uh what you're talking about to
some extent is What's called the
anthropic principle and that is it's no
coincidence that we observe that we're
in one of those universes that had the
conditions necessary and for for you to
have life
because nobody's in those other
universes to notice that they're in a
sterile universe
what the mind then starts doing is
saying what's the ratios
are there gazillions of sterile
universes for everyone that gets people
sitting on stage asking silly questions
about parallel universes that they're
never going to see anyway
well that's where Lee smolen comes in
because if there's evolvability of
universes and this multiplicity of
universes uh are not the laws aren't
random
but they're inherited and refined by
Evolution then the vast majority of our
sister universes
have beckoned life in them
and a majority of them have
at least some bipeds
in auditoriums
talking about this
and if you spursed it out
a boss the Infinite Space
some of those by heads will be me
wearing mostly black
and
um
and answering questions from somebody
wearing white
I can't uh maybe we'll move it up
somewhere in the middle there but I
can't stress enough no matter how long
our universe may last or Multiverse we
must keep paying your taxes I think
right over there
yes I wanted to say something about the
anthropic principle it's always
described in terms of very narrow
uh tolerances on any one parameter but
Vic stenger among other people have
shown that a few very several parameters
at once you may get very strange
universes but they still have complex
matter or should
and also there's actually another paper
out with uh describing a possible
Universe with complex matter and there's
therefore possibly life that doesn't
even have a weak nuclear force
so I think that the range of variation
is really much wider than most people
think oh well even if you have a lot of
even if you have a universe where it's
hard to have a
Goldilocks zone these Goldilocks zones
that Andy showed you know around around
Stars perfect for water on the surface
of the planet
we now realize that it's highly likely
that there are oceans still in the
universe covered with ice worlds like
Europa Enceladus we now believe that
there are as many as it doesn't worlds
in our solar system that could be abodes
for life because they have liquid water
under conditions that have some energy
um so even if the Earth weren't here
which means that almost all of the solar
systems probably have some
even if the star is not stable even if
there's no Goldilocks zone if if matter
condensed
and there's a snow
barrier and the end and there are ice
worlds there's probably something that
could have life in almost any solar
system
yeah this is a very very good question
because we don't know enough about the
the conditions that are necessary for
life to know whether or not there could
be other islands in the parameter space
of the Multiverse where very different
kinds of Life Could evolve I think we
need to exercise do humility here and
recognize that we we don't know what
would happen if you change multiple
constants at the same time people like
Victor stenger and others are just
starting to think about this it's
definitely an open question these are
why these these questions are so
exciting there's so much more to do of
all the exciting photos that I've seen
the Viking Lander and so many others
from our space program the thing that
jazzed me the most was the image of an
ocean Shoreline clear River patterns
mountains
on Titan
the huygen space probe showed what it
clearly oceans of methane
and
gasoline and mountains made of wax
overlying ice
I mean if there are living beings there
they would be made of wax
and we some of you in this room
will live in a civilization that
actually goes there and finds out I'm
hoping almost all of us okay so maybe
we'll take uh one more this guy's had
his hand up yeah let's bring it up front
and then both him will finish up
all right
all right so um talking about the um uh
universes inside black holes or being
created by black holes um if that were
the case
um and our universe were inside a black
hole
um or any Universe like that
um wouldn't there continually be more
stuff in the universe like it would be
expanding but not only adding space but
but but matter as well that's coming
through as well
yeah and you want to tackle that it's
it's an interesting question what the
relationship is between the inside and
the outside
and there's a certain question it could
be very very much that we were kind of
screened off from anything that's
happening outside in in the cases where
Singularity is formed in a new sort of
universe you know pinches off
the the relationship between the parent
and child might might end
um so in that case you might not be
dealing with an influx of new new matter
um let's say there are other more
complicated ways that space-time can be
intersecting like wormholes it very well
may be that if stable wormholes exist
then indeed you could see an influx of
matter going through from a distant part
in space and time and you know if you're
asking the question about our universe
um we certainly don't see evidence of of
giant agglomerations of matter appearing
out of nowhere
um so you know maybe that uh maybe you
know if we're inside of a black hole
we're not necessarily you know at the
other end of a wormhole but these are
all very interesting open questions and
it's it's certainly a fun and exciting
thing to think about and it's actually
amazing that uh you you can think about
these things and then you think okay
wait wait a second how can we
experimentally test for the existence of
wormholes particles of matter would be
traveling in slightly different ways
around wormholes than around normal
black holes this is something that
astronomers might eventually be able to
detect and if those are detected Not
only would that be Nobel prize winning
it would be the kind of a thing that
would allow us to realize that some of
these places would seem inaccessible
forever are actually not necessarily in
principle and accessible I certainly
hope that the Universe ends up being a
place where the ideas we can think of
are also ideas that we can test and and
that that's an aesthetic bias I don't
know if that'll be borne out but it
certainly it certainly would be a little
a little bit more kind if the universe
wasn't playing a cruel joke on us that
we could think of these things so let's
all turn to the simulators who are
running this simulation
you know hey how about it here no I'm
thinking our response I'll always turn
always turn to the third wall all the
time because that way you can tell the
simulators
I know I know and we never got around
too much about theology but that's
another time so see you all on August
11th for the next sciflex movie and uh
next Arthur C Clarke Center for human
imagination event thank you all for
coming thank you thank you thank you
very much
[Music]